all right uh very good offseason at
least more recently for jared goff the
rams have signed him to a contract with
33.5 million dollars per year in new
money
neither of us picked jared goff in
today's draft which was which teams
could have buyer's remorse regarding
quarterbacks why didn't we pick jared i
kind of felt like it was just the
obvious thing and it was the jumping-off
point of the draft
where i wanted to have more
conversations maybe
about other guys i mean do i have
buyer's remorse or would i have a little
bit buyer's remorse paying jared goff
you know 34 million dollars a year yeah
i would to a degree i don't think he is
the type of talent that carries a
football team week in and week out like
some of the other quarterbacks that are
are paid in his in his stratosphere uh i
don't but at the same time i also
recognize that the rams they got a guy
there's not a lot of these guys out
there on the street and they feel
comfortable with where he's at um
and and the biggest thing is this is
just the world we've come into in the
nfl it's the next quarterback up gets
the next big contract and and trumps
everybody except for you know in this
case russell wilson uh and ben
roethlisberger who yes he's not even in
their class or their stratosphere at
this point but that's the way of the nfl
and the perception and public pressure
around it is that jared goff is a big
time franchise quarterback and the rams
for that are are backed into a corner to
a degree you gave the very common sense
honest transparent answer as to why
neither of us picked jared goff we had
talked about jared goff throughout the
show this gave us a chance to talk about
some others the lawyer answered why we
didn't pick him here's the lawyer
if you want to defend why we didn't pick
him number one we don't know the
structure of the deal yes that's right
it may be a deal that the rams can
easily escape maybe there isn't a lot of
money up front until we know the
structure we won't know how much regret
they could have also
by the time we get to the point where
the rams would be saying oh man we may
have paid this guy too much money the
market may have exploded right and they
may look at it and say
33 and a half million per year for this
guy's a pretty good deal because patrick
mahomes is making 43 and baker
mayfield's making 44. yeah and kyler
murray is making 42 and hey 33 and a
half for golf you know and the salary
caps 220 million per year per team yeah
that we don't have regret because we got
to have a quarterback and this is a
pretty good deal in year four five and
six so there's a chance they won't have
buyer's remorse because they know that
they're buying at a time when they could
be on the cusp of feeling like almost
like the panthers with cam newton they
don't have buyer's remorse yeah they
gave him a market value contract at the
time he signed right but it's 20 million
a year right hey this is great because
look what the market has done so that
would be the lawyer's answer as to why
we omitted jared goff that's real that's
fair and you know my football answer is
franchise quarterbacks got to deliver
when the coaching staff or some of the
players aren't at their best and that's
my big question now we sought a little
in the saints game okay in the nfc
championship game but the saints play
man-to-man like almost every play so
that's not it's not real hard to just
figure out what the saints are doing but
when it was the bears or the eagles or
the new england patriots the plays were
not made there in those games that you
would expect a guy 34 million dollars a
year to be making or a franchise
quarterback i can promise you that
mahomes rogers carson wentz and some of
those guys would have hit the first wide
open post in the super bowl and then
certainly would have hit the other one
that we talk about in the back of the
end zone where the guy was standing
there waving his arm for a period of
time and then he threw a fluttering ball
in the back of the end zone to wear a
corner who was 30 yards away got the
ball in time and knocked it down see
those are just little things that i have
to see he's gonna have to prove me wrong
and i hope he does because it's not
personal this is just business and
football that he's worthy of this type
of contractor being that kind of guy i'm
glad you mentioned that play because
yesterday peter king used the example of
the first time they ran that play and
brandon cooks popped wide open in the
first half of the super bowl as evidence
that moving forward sean mcvay is going
to say that's your first read well i
guarantee you by the time they did it
the second time in that game yes mcveigh
had said to jared goff that's your first
thing that's why they did it again yes
they could say all they want mike that
play i promise you mike he's run it
since high school it is not in a
complicated play you play madden video
games right it's one guy going on a post
and one guy going on a deep cross and
they play action packs whoa they
reinvented the freaking wheel there holy
crap that is a truly like some people
call that play ncaa because it's just
it's in every college team's playbook
he's been running that play forever
there's no excuses for that sean
mcveigh's done a great job to defuse it
and put the blame on himself so the
public doesn't get on jared goff
mcveigh's been great at massaging and
bringing goffer along his whole career
and that's why i say to this point he's
still more of a system guy than i look
as a franchise guy when you play madden
a lot you realize how simple football
can sure right i'll run the same pass
play over and over again and i can tell
by the alignment pre-snap right who's
going to be open right and then once the
defensive start once the linebacker and
the safety starts moving i know which
guy is going to be open we're in the
same damn play sure this guy x button
this time triangle button this time
circle button this time and i know it's
more complicated than that no but some
of these plays they are that simple they
are that you make that read based upon
where the safety goes where the
linebacker goes whether it's man or zone
whatever the case may be and you know
who's going to be open yes and you throw
the ball and that's that right and the
great teams that play against those
teams where you go oh i got we have our
plays and we're good at them we execute
them you know the great defenses they go
oh i know they like to run this in these
formations i'm going to put people in
all the areas where oh they think they
know the reeds but oh gosh we're going
to have people every time he looks at
first rate oh god there's a guy there oh
second guy oh gosh there's a guy there
oh third guy oh now now i gotta scramble
and it's just absolutely backyard
football or that guy that you think is
moving one way and he ends up moving the
other way and then by the time you let
go of the ball it's you're going about
no i'm gonna throw it in slow motion
it's a horrible feeling it's a horrible
feeling you're familiar with that i'm
very familiar
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports